les annonces des manuels macron du 12
juillet relative aux nouvelles
restrictions ont fait grincer des dents
parce sanitaire étendue exigé pour de
très nombreuses activités vaccination
des soignants obligatoire à la rentrée
d'autres chefs d'état ont pris peu ou
prou les mêmes mesures comme la grèce
l'italie le royaume uni la russie sans
déclencher la colère des citoyens le
savez déjà le prince de la start up
nation n'est pas vraiment le roi de la
com comme si c'était contagieux ses
porte paroles ne brille pas non plus
dans l'exercice
allez c'est cadeau on commence par
gabriela talent le roi du calembour se
vacciner c'est un petit pas pour soi
mais c'est un grand pas pour l'immunité
on se souviendra toute notre vie des
désopilante mascarade si bête
ndiaye les françaises ne pourront pas
acheter de masse dans les pharmacies
parce que ce n'est pas nécessaire quand
on n'est pas malade
dès le début de la pandémie en avril
2020 le média arrêt sur image avait
établi un classement de cette chef de
l'exécutif concernant l'accès au
journaliste emmanuel macron était arrivé
bon dernier
les autres dirigeants organisées
quasiment tous de vrais conférence de
presse lors desquelles il était
interviewé par des journalistes au
canada justin trudeau convoque les
journalistes en présentiel et leur
réponds aux états unis même hostile aux
médias donald trump tenait dé point
presse régulier
en présence de journalistes qui
pouvaient poser des questions même si
ces rendez-vous tourner vite à la
bataille rangée ou au discours lunaire
de l'ancien président joe biden organise
également des conférences de presse
durant lesquels ils acceptent ou non
plusieurs questions de journalistes
même chose pour angela merkel et fait
notable la chancelière c'est reconnaître
ses erreurs
elle avait demandé la fermeture des
commerces et l'interdiction des
locations de vacances à pâques elle a
rétropédalé et s'en est immédiatement
excusé en toute humilité une erreur doit
être appelée une erreur et plus
important encore elle doit être corrigé
ici possible à temps je sais que cette
proposition a provoqué une incertitude
supplémentaire
je le regrette profondément
et pour cela je demande pardon à tous
les citoyens du miel pour nos oreilles
moins satisfaisants au royaume uni les
conférences de presse sont régulièrement
organisées par boris johnson
les journalistes peuvent poser des
questions mais à distance et ne peuvent
donc pas rebondir sur les réponses
apportées mais emmanuel macron
à lui carrément adopté un tout autre
style le solo depuis son entrée en
fonction les relations sont mauvaises
avec les médias il a déclaré je cite les
journalistes ne m'intéresse pas ce sont
les français qui m'intéresse socrates
direz mais vous êtes français vous les
journalistes de l'hexagone donc emmanuel
macron devrait s'intéresser à vous eh
bien non il a écarté nos consoeurs et
confrères ils filtrent l'accès aux
déplacements présidentiels choisi les
journalistes accrédités
certains événements ne sont pas ouverts
aux médias et l'équipe présidentielle
puis alors les vidéos qui conforte
l'image du chef de l'état bref ce mandat
irrite la profession des dizaine de
confrères ont été blessés durant les
manifestations des gilet jaune
huit ont été convoqués par la dgsi pour
leur enquête en 2019
une loi sur le secret des affaires qui
peut entraver la profession a été voté
le projet de loi sur la sécurité globale
qui menaçait la couverture des actions
policières a fait défiler les
journalistes et pour ses communications
sur le co vide
emmanuel macron se tient seul face à une
caméra il connaît la réticence d'un
grand nombre de français a accepté la
vaccination et la restriction des
libertés individuelles
mais il ne cherche pas en discuter face
à la presse et une fois la locution
terminé il laisse ses porte-paroles
ministre détaillé est explicite et
l'oracle
quel courage et surtout cela creuse
encore davantage l'écart avec la
population ah mais j'oubliais il y a
tout de même des analystes politiques
auquel le président a accepté de
répondre les youtuber carlito et mcfly
ils n'ont pas leur carte de presse mais
savent éviter les sujets qui fâchent
quelle belle leçon de communication